moi c'est pas l'école que j'ai connu moi
j'ai pas connu une école où on séparer
les filles des garçons il y avait je
voulais dire qu'il ya déjà ça c'est pas
une école de cinéma parle tout seul
c'est bon c'est bon c'est pas c'est pas
un truc et on rigole avec ça alors c'est
bon
parce que quand je vois des remises à la
raison j'ai mal au coeur quand je vois
des reportages comme ça c'est pas la
france où il a vu le reportage je l' ai
vu en entier j'ai vu cet après midi je
me suis fait chier regardez tout
l'après-midi exprès pour elle tout à
fait mais je me suis fait chier pour
être au top ce soir pour en parler pas
l'or battait la france qui change dans
le boycott change pas d'aujourd'hui je
comprends pas le boycott parce que c'est
des choses qui existent en vrai il faut
pas mettre le comme vous avez dit à
l'heure sous le tapis mais vous causer
de persuader que ce qu'on trouve de tout
et 2 ne m'interrompez ce que je veux
c'est que qu'on laisse tranquille les
enfants je ne supporte pas qu'on
apprenne le coran à des enfants de trois
ans si on veut leur apprendre à la
maison il n'y a pas de souci à l'école
on peut leur apprendre l'arabe sans leur
expliquer le coran je veux que les
enfants décident de tout seul sur le
restaurant des filles tout à l'heure
quand c'est des adultes si le restaurant
il n'y a pas cette demande le restaurant
ne fonctionnerait pas ça veut dire qu'il
ya une demande des femmes qui veulent
aller manger dans des boxes moi ça me
choque de voir des femmes qui vont
manger dans des boxes j'ai pas envie de
cette france là j'ai envie que j'ai
envie que ça reste dans les lois de la
république
j'ai pas envie qu'on soit contre la
république quand on fait des choses s'il
ya des s'assure des associations qui
sont moqués montée qu'elle reste dans le
cadre de la république dès que ça sort
de la république ça me plaît pas voilà
maintenant sur lui mais je laime
d'accord c'est maintenant qu ils sont
d'accord
placez une et maintenant je suis
complètement rincé que je vais tout ce
que je voulais dire
ouais j'espère meilleur pour les adultes
sont cathos qui durera ce métier parce
que j'ai tutoyé non non non c'est pas ça
mais moi je veux pas leurs suffrages et
le couple a frappé alors oui mais vous
comme ça ah oui bah ça sur un sol trop
grave je voudrais juste revenir sur le
coran moi quand j'étais petit j'allais
au catéchisme et j'apprenais la bible
voilà il en a trop dit non mais ce que
je veux dire c'est comme dans la
religion catholique on lit la bible très
tôt tout petit lire le coran c'est le
comprendre c'est éviter ont très vite à
mettre vraiment pas par le coulage des
samoa fini on t'apprend pas parler en
français avec la bible c'est pas vrai
non mais t'as froid parlant français
avec des règles c'est qu'avec la le
coran n'est pas forcément champions et
produire leurs effets de l'appréciation
du salaire d'un scandale mêlant argent
et islam is me révèle que la mairie de
roubaix sinon ce serait une association
de soutien scolaire effectuerez en fait
des cours coraniques à des enfants âgés
de trois ans et donc ce dont parlait
rêvons un instant regardez l'extrait
j'ai signalé cette association qui sous
prétexte de cours de soutien scolaire
effectué en réalité des cours coraniques
à des gamins âgés de 3 ans là c'est une
association qui j'allais avec des fonds
publics dans des locaux qui
appartiennent à la ville de roubaix donc
c'est ça qui me gêne au fil des années
et discrètement l'association a hier
aurait ajouté à ses activités des cours
d'arabe
qui se serait transformé en cours de
religion amine a retrouvé des documents
qui étaient distribués aux enfants sur
les cahiers de textes des élèves on peut
lire révisé sourate al massad ou encore
apprendre sourate al fatiha
donc évidemment c'est pas des cours de
langue arabe on peut parfaitement
apprendre l'arabe cents à prendre à des
enfants de 3 ans le coran alors oui
j'entends ce que vous dites mais moi
franchement moi non non non j'entends le
reportage honnêtement je ne suis pas
choqué si on peut décrypter le coran
pour éviter des abus monsieur sait très
bien en revanche votre boulot sur
l'association formidable parce que vous
avez la dénoncer quelque chose qui va se
terminer en justice et ça c'est vrai que
j'ai bien regardé c'est vous qui avez
fait tout le boulot en amont là je vous
tire mon chapeau parce que cette
association scandaleuse il faut pas
aller trop loin quand tu vois des
lycéennes à la fac qui est des
étudiantes à la fin qui vont d'ailleurs
un ascenseur pour aller prier alors on
l'a alors c'est pas ça la magie au
prince à
l'extrême ont au moins ils ont trop loin
dans le délire mais c'est pas du délire
de bloquer
expression langage de
l'espace
dans
l'immédiat
ce qui s'est passé avec un strap je vois
la laïcité tout ça ouais
c'est ici
pas d'accord ça c'est la petite frieda
vicieux oui ok
vraiment tu disais non je dis que ça
n'existait pas avant et on vivait bien
ensemble moi gvg j'ai grandi avec des
centristes je suis triste parce que
c'est ma raison c'est que c'est triste
parce que c'est ce qu'ils arrivent à
faire il arrive à séparer les gens
pourquoi on en arrive là aujourd'hui
parce qu'aujourd'hui un algérien
marocain tunisien ou autres il n'est pas
chez lui au maroc et les pachys lui en
france c'est ça qu'on a réussi on a
réussi à les réunir maintenant ils
cherchent des leviers ils essayent à
être entre maintenant c'est ça qu'on a
réussi à faire à force à force de
diviser comme ça et de dire bah lui le
c'est un méchant lui c'est un bon
maintenant ils font des trucs qui font
des écoles entre eux parce qu'ils
veulent plus que leur école et dans
l'enfant d'un rappel à la république de
l'école parce que parce qu'il ya du
parce que y'a du jambon parce que lui
s'appelle comme ça parce qu'il s'appelle
comme ça c'était pas comme ça avance
pour ça que je suis très triste et c'est
pour ça que c'est un sujet pour moi qui
est sérieux parce que comme on a dit à
l'heure là vous avez les le pen et les
zemmour dans leurs fauteuils qui disent
allez-y c'est cadeau c'est pour moi
c'est ça qui m'énerve moi ça le samoan
triste parce que ça parce que ça existe
faut pas faire comme si ça n'existait
pas voilà